very cool okay hdq is the guy who
guessed the magic number 62 number wing
number range was 55 through 77
five-minute English opening but it's
still to be determined
what will black through my way okay
staying quite flexible and move one in
let's go with this ECL code 822 English
Carl's Bremen system all right let's
take here get my bishop developed I've
had trouble with this opening on the
white end in the past um when I see this
move I think is their way to exploit b7
mmm I wonder about that I don't think
that there is tonight takes pawn takes I
build my Center I open up the beef ah
I'd love to see Knight takes Knight
because then the the pressure against b7
is that much more powerful because my
rook can converge on that square as well
this seems awkward because the Queen
isn't defending d5 so it's attacked once
defended once I'm considering this and
my eyes right now is unprotected can I
take advantage of this fact you know
what's typical is to I think bring the
knight out to c6 or right now what I'm
thinking of are what are the differences
between 96 and Bishop d6 what what does
this move not do that knight c6 would do
that's the big question I'm asking and I
think it's has to do with this d4 square
I think I should play this right now so
let's get this break in I do have a
two-to-one majority in the center after
I did captured like this this is just
dropping the pawn and I don't think that
there's any tricks associated with it
no I don't believe so there could be a
bishop check and well I could block with
the bishop I wouldn't be able to come
back to c3 that's hit twice so I'm up a
pond from this position and I'm just
going to continue with development
castling is one of them and I think the
other thing is to get this Knight back
to c3 to challenge the farthest advance
night this guy on d5 and I'm looking to
push for it in the center it's now a 2
to 0 majority time is not that big of an
issue and I'm just going to advance put
this in pre move and from here I guess
c5 is something I would be anticipating
after a capture if we do see that and if
I could if I really want to I think I
could go ahead and win this Bishop after
d5 grab some space bishop here's forest
h3 Bishop back g4 bishop here let me
just do this I'm threatening to win the
bishop put the d5 that's the big bad
threat D 5 D 5 maybe c6 is needed Bishop
here maybe could be played and now he's
dead he's a cooked bishop right
time is level d5 is going to be winning
the bishop so I think the earlier
portion with Bishop d6 was already the
start of something that's a little bit
off so it'll be something to take away I
believe from the earlier deployment of
the black pieces less than three now
from here I'm just focused on trades
being up material now I don't want any
complications whatsoever I don't want to
weaken my Kings side there's no need to
make any more pawn moves these guys are
going to stay as is Bishop here to f4
rook on my rooks ideally on the C file
and D file since they're the ones that
are most likely going to be opened up
okay take with the pawn of the night and
take with the pawn gain some space and
do so with the tempo on the bishop now
the e-file is completely open so this is
purposeful I'm not sure what I want to
do with my dark square bishop just yet
let me see if I could induce some
weaknesses with this push this becomes a
hole okay so I'm fine with that
as little I was provoking that type of
move I'm okay to come back I'm now
keying in on e6 I could come there with
tempo like d4 hits the bishop and if it
drops back and night to e6 is going to
land a fork if Knight e5 I guess I could
consider trading this right here is
maybe going to be a little bit of
annoying and I just want to avoid all
and any complications
so I'm perfectly okay with giving up the
bishop pair it's a significant advantage
being up this material so I'm hitting
the bishop and now more than welcome to
more exchanges and that's what we're now
to have I will take with the bunt with
my pond because he becomes past and my
bishop is opened up so I'll be looking
for more than one reason behind each of
my moves if possible so those are two or
two reasons to go with that particular
capture and I don't know that the I
guess the Queen exchange could be
avoided but not now
trade trade trade from here and there's
not much else to do there's only one
peace of mind that isn't playing rook a
to d1 this diagonal has opened up okay
we have resignation all right good game
HD q let's back up now I am definitely
not the opening expert for sure I
believe that this is fine and this is
where I start to worry a little bit just
in general placing note being familiar
with this being in the half-open file
keep your minor pieces off of it I think
it's important to maybe have a more
direct view of this particular advance
and you know what even backing up at
this moment here I think what's also a
move after Bishop g2 is to not defend
the knight with Bishop to e6 but rather
play Knight to b6 and the main idea
behind this this is going to be
important detail because it'll let you
know that it moves such as Bishop d6 is
not the way to go
the idea behind it this particular move
after Bishop g2 Knight b6 the idea
behind it is to have your Queen there to
watch over d4 so that I don't have this
freeing advance in d4 if I could get
this particular break in I'm doing I'm
doing pretty well so this move is aimed
at preventing this advance and after a
move like Knight f3 which is supporting
it enough then you play Knight to c6 and
you're defending it enough and finishing
up development wise I think you could
then be running with Bishop e7
Bishop e6 Castle and well we'll be going
from there but I think at least the
placement of the minor pieces to
consider Knight b6 at this very moment
knight c6 Bishop e7 Bishop e6 Castle we
go from there follow up moves might
include Queen to d7 and placing a rook
on the d8 square may be the King ruck
and I guess one last point is that in
those types of positions it's important
to recognize that this c5 square is a
soft point ideas of like Nike for to c5
are available this rook will most likely
be placed on c1 and supporting that
Knight movement so that's I'm just
giving you some quick insight as to
maybe a setup you can be running forward
with on the black end in this particular
opening one that again I've struggled
with on the white end okay let me close
out of this